this is the deepest and most detailed
image of the universe we've ever seen it
contains previously unknown galaxies and
among them the oldest yet recorded
unveiling it at the white house joe
biden's mind seemed blown
light from the oldest galaxies the
oldest documented light in the history
of the universe from over
13 billion let me say that again 13
billion years ago
it's hard to even fathom
it'll create it it's right there and
these are the people controlling the
james webb space telescope that brought
it to us we've been working on this for
20 years or more and and i need to trust
the engineers who
launched this into space and built
everything so i expected this to go well
and uh and it has you should be prepared
to be wowed
this is a huge moment for the mission
engineers web is so big fitting it on a
rocket meant the six ton telescope had
to fold then unfold itself once in space
that went without a hitch and now it can
get to work this is the flight control
room for the web telescope the only
place on earth with a direct link to the
observatory that's currently orbiting
the earth
all the way out beyond the moon
and on this monitor here a real-time
image
of the telescope's view into the
universe web isn't just a better
telescope it can see things we've never
seen before planets beyond our solar
system and whether they have atmospheres
like ours the first stars that made the
molecules of all life and of course how
the universe came to be
looking back from today on earth our sun
was born about 5 billion years ago but
the universe itself made by the big bang
some 13.8 billion years ago while other
telescopes have looked deep into space
before we still know next to nothing
about this period a billion years after
the big bang but webb can reach that far
by seeing infrared the light from a star
for example 12 billion years ago has
taken so long getting to us it's
effectively been stretched by the
expanding universe from visible
wavelengths to infrared seeing that is
the only way to image the most distant
things in space
this new image is just a first glimpse
from the webb telescope it's already
changed the way we see the cosmos but
over its anticipated 20-year lifetime it
will change the way we understand it too
tom clark sky news washington